sollen kinder und jugendliche nun auch
geimpft werden so eine richtig klare
antwort die gab es heute beim impf
gipfel im kanzleramt nicht denn sie
können sich ab dem siebten juni impfen
lassen wenn die priorisierung aufgehoben
wird
aber mehr impfstoff für die zwölf- bis
18-jährigen wird es nicht geben
kommt jetzt also der run auf die
kinderärzte und ist eine impfung
überhaupt sinnvoll obwohl kinder ja nur
selten schwer erkranken
es gibt verunsicherung bei den eltern
und schulen sollen unabhängig davon
öffnen und auch urlaub soll für
ungeimpfte kinder möglich sein
corona gipfel bei merkel wer bekommt den
impfstoff unser thema in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
für uns war ganz wichtig zwei aussagen
das erste ein sicherer schulbetrieb wird
auch in zukunft völlig unabhängig von
der frage sein ob ein kind geimpft ist
oder ob ein kind nicht geimpftes noch
mal daran erinnern dass sowohl für die
kita kinder als auch für die
grundschulkinder auf absehbarer zeit gar
keine in die zulassung da sein wird aber
auch für die zwölf- bis 18-jährigen gilt
der sichere schulbetrieb ist unabhängig
von der frage zu betrachten
ob kinder geimpft sind oder nicht wie
wichtig ist es trotzdem kinder und
jugendliche zu impfen darüber und über
all die anderen themen des impfgipfel
sprechen wir herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf meine gäste vorstellen
hier im studio dr martin terhardt er ist
mitglied der ständigen impfkommission
kurz stiko er hat lange als kinderarzt
gearbeitet und zur zeit arbeitete er in
einem impfzentrum hier in berlin
ich begrüße christina dunst sie ist
stellvertretende leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros des redaktions netzwerk
deutschland kurz rnd und war vorhin auch
bei der pressekonferenz im kanzleramt
zugeschaltet ist uns dr christoph specht
er ist medizinjournalist von beruf
orthopäde und als ärztliche ratgeber oft
im fernsehen zu sehen und nahm herr
specht und herzlich willkommen dario
schramm bundes schülersprecher und
gerade hat er sein abitur gemacht an der
integrierten gesamtschule paffrath in
bergisch gladbach also die letzte
prüfung ist geschafft herr schramm
herzlichen glückwunsch dazu die note
haben sie ja noch nicht du willst du sie
wollte erst mal bevor sie jetzt wirklich
feiern ihr abitur oder ihre
abiturprüfungen schauen wir mal auf den
impf gipfel denn sie setzen sich ja nur
mal für die belange der kinder und
schüler und schülerinnen 1
da ist jetzt nicht so viel rausgekommen
beim impfgipfel insofern es wurde gesagt
es gibt keinen zusätzlichen impfstoff
aber ab dem 7 juni können sich kinder
und jugendliche bis 18 jahren davor ab
12 jahren eben auch impfen lassen ab 16
jahren geht das ja jetzt schon was
halten sie von diesem ergebnis man muss
sich anschauen gesundheitsminister
sparen hat jetzt eben vergangene woche
angekündigt bis ende august soll jeder
schüler und jede schülerin ein
für angebot bekommen da waren natürlich
einige und auch viele erwartungen daran
gebunden und trotz vieler misserfolge in
der bildungspolitik hat man trotzdem
gedacht okay jetzt kommt wirklich das
versprechen wir können uns darauf
verlassen dieser impfgipfel man dachte
jetzt kommt eben der klare konkrete plan
wie soll das funktionieren
ich war auch der festen überzeugung dass
kann damit funktionieren dass es eben
prioritäre verteilung von dem impfstoff
biontech für junge menschen gibt alles
nicht geschehen es gibt keinen klaren
plan und im endeffekt ist die aussage
junge menschen wenn dann der stoff
zugelassen ist könnt euch mit in das
getümmel der termin buchungen rhein
stürzen aber bevorzugt oder in
irgendeiner weise eine hilfestellung
werdet ihr nicht erhalten
und das heißt das sie sind enttäuscht
davon absolut denn wir müssen uns
anschauen das ist schon ein riesen
gerangel wir sind zwar noch in dieser in
priorisierung drin aber wir erleben das
glaube ich alle tagtäglich im alltag
alle versuchen irgendwie diesen termin
zu bekommen
und wenn wir uns jetzt überlegen junge
menschen zwölf oder 13 jahre die sind
angewiesen auf ihre eltern die sind
darauf angewiesen dass die sich jetzt in
diesem getümmel mit reinstellen und von
daher kinder müssen wir jetzt auch
gerade wenn es ums impfen gehen einfach
noch mal besonders schützen und auch
besonders unterstützen und das ist
einfach in diesen impfgipfel ja nicht
als lösung oder kein ansatz irgendwie zu
erkennen hertha hat als mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission sie haben ja
nicht eine klare empfehlung gegeben dass
es sinnvoll ist kinder und jugendliche
zu impfen
wie wichtig wäre es denn kinder und
jugendliche jetzt priorität zu impfen so
wie es dario schreiben sich wünscht also
wir haben noch keine empfehlung
ausgesprochen wir sind noch im
beratungsprozess ist ein durchaus
aufwendiges verfahren den wir
verpflichtet sind natürlich erwarte dass
wir ende nächster woche wahrscheinlich
zum abschluss kommen werden und anfang
übernächster woche unsere entscheidung
dann auch veröffentlicht wird generell
ist dieser impfstoff für kinder in dem
alter geeignet das hat die
amerikanischen behörden festgelegt dass
wird sicherlich auch morgen die
europäische behörde festlegen
wir haben in der stiko die aufgabe zu
entscheiden welche risiken abgewogen
werden müssen und wie der impfstoff am
besten am effektivsten in welcher
reihenfolge vielleicht auch doch noch
mal eingesetzt werden kann und diese
entscheidung ist noch nicht gefallen im
raum steht ja stehen ja im prinzip zwei
alternativen entweder eine generelle
impfempfehlung für alle 12 bis 10
zehnjährigen oder nur eine empfehlung
für risikopersonen auch in dieser
altersgruppe mit chronischen
erkrankungen die ein höheres risiko
haben durch eine infektion schwerer zu
erkranken wo die waagschale hinfällig
das kann ich jetzt noch nicht verraten
das weiß ich auch noch nicht genau
hätten sie sich gewünscht dass die
politik ihre empfehlung abwarte bevor so
eine ankündigung von
bundesgesundheitsminister kam von es
wäre doch gut wenn jetzt die kinder und
jugendlichen auch ein angebot bekommen
ich denke das ist sicherlich unglücklich
gelaufen wie so manches unglücklich
gelaufen ist dass man halt diesen
erwartungsdruck erzeugt hat ohne genau
zu wissen wie die empfehlung hinterher
aussieht aber es ist ja nicht das erste
mal dass die zulassungsbehörde
vielleicht eine andere entscheidung
fällt als die stiko das haben wir bis
jetzt habe astrazeneca auch erlebt jetzt
bei johnson johnson auch mit den
altersbeschränkungen erlebt und ich
denke das könnten wir auch wenn es so
weit käme auch hier durchhalten aber das
hauptproblem ist das was wir schon haben
auch gesagt haben es gibt einfach nicht
genügend impfstoff um jetzt ganz schnell
diese versprechungen gemacht worden und
diese erwartungen die ausgelöst werden
allzu auszufüllen kunst wie empfinden
sie das sie haben ja jetzt schon mehrere
runden im kanzleramt den
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
der beobachtet heute warm und ging es ja
relativ flott also von 14 glaube ich bis
18 uhr ungefähr und man war sich auf
einmal irgendwie einig aber hat eben
dann nicht das gemacht was der
bundesgesundheitsminister eigentlich
angekündigt hat was war das denn heute
vom gipfel ja ich glaube dass die
[Musik]
regierungsvertreter und die
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsident vor allem auf die
ständige impfkommission gehofft hatten
dass die empfehlung früher vorliegt und
dahinter haben sich heute eigentlich
alles so ein bisschen verschanzt also
die frage wie klar jetzt die politik das
empfiehlt das die priorisierung für
kinder zugunsten von kinder und
jugendlichen dann genannt werden würde
da haben sich heute alles ein bisschen
dahinter versteckt immer verwiesen auf
die stiko die noch keine empfehlung
abgegeben habe der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder hat dann
gesagt naja wenn die stiko das als
unbedingt wichtig erklärt hätte hätte
sich die politik anders verhalten und
die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt die
politik kann keine neben empfehlung zur
stiko abgeben und damit ist jetzt ab dem
siebten juni wenn sie bis dahin noch
nicht klar entschieden haben sollten
die verantwortung bei eltern bei eltern
und ärzte eigentlich in die ärzte werden
vermutlich ungern impfen bevor wiederum
die stiko nicht die klare empfehlung
abgegeben hat und insofern ist eine
terminkollision ja etwas gewesen und nun
sagt die politik die stiko ist zu
langsam oder einige sagen dass und die
stiko sagt wir brauchen die zeit die
kann dann hat sie heute auch noch mal da
verteidigt und hat gesagt sie schätzt
sehr wie genau sie das nehmen aber es
ist jetzt ein datum von dem cabriolet
zugleich wird gesagt das ist nicht
genügend in losen gibt dass sich das da
verzögert und damit ist im moment der
die karte bei eltern und ärzten darüber
zu entscheiden bzw einen druck
aufzubauen
herr specht wir empfinden sie es ist er
hat die politik sich sozusagen die
verantwortung weggegeben eben an eltern
und an ärzten was bedeutet diese
entscheidung dass ab dem 17 juni jetzt
eben die kinder und jugendlichen dann
wenn dich die größe empfiehlt so einfach
mit dazu kommen jetzt vom prinzip was
wir da heute gehört haben waren einig
selbstverständlichkeiten nämlich wenn
der impfstoff in eine erweiterte
zulassung bekommt auch für kinder
beziehungsweise 12 bis 15 jährige dann
wird man diese kinder impfen können rein
prinzipiell das ist eigentlich
selbstverständlich die entscheidende
frage ist ja sollte man sie in fünf
allen dingen muss man sie impfen und ich
bin ausgesprochen dankbar dass die stiko
sich die zeit nimmt und die daten
anschaut und das sagt ein extremer
impfbefürworter als den ich mich
bezeichnen möchte wenn ich bedenke was
weltweit impfungen für gute erfolge
gezeigt hat millionen von menschen von
kindern sind gerettet worden durch
impfungen aber eine impfung ist immer
eine individuelle entscheidung ich muss
immer nutzen und risiko abwägen und wenn
wie in diesem fall zwar das risiko von
vermutlich auch sehr sehr gering ist
dann muss ich aber trotzdem einen
höheren nutzen haben und das ist für
mich sehr fraglich wie hoch ist der
nutzen bei kindern erst recht wenn wir
die ganz kleinen reden da sprechen wir
jetzt noch nicht von das wird wenn
überhaupt erst nächstes jahr
aktuell werden aber auch bei den zwölf-
bis 15-jährigen wie hoch ist das risiko
einen schweren kopf 19 verlauf sehr sehr
gering und wenn wir dann eben diese
nutzen rechnung machen nutzen und risiko
rechnung dann wird das da schon länger
also die stiko tod meines erachtens
völlig gut daran und recht daran sich
die daten genauer anzugucken und wenn
sie zum ergebnis kommt dass eben nur
kinder mit vorerkrankungen da wäre ich
dann auch absolut dafür weil sie ein
höheres risiko haben wenn da nur diese
geimpft werden sollen
dann wäre das völlig in ordnung ich
verstehe aber natürlich letzter satz
auch herrn schramm der sagt gibt mir
endlich mal dieses ding und die forscher
um bestimmungen frage habe ich heute
gelesen von fast 70 prozent der eltern
und schüler sagen ja wir wollen diese
impfung haben aber ich glaube dass
hauptgrund der hauptgrund dafür ist
nicht weil wir alle so wahnsinnig
überzeugt sind von dem extremen nutzen
dieser impfung bei den kindern sondern
die wollen den stempel haben die wollen
das weltweit ersten wie auch immer also
hat sie die freiheit gibt genau wir
haben sie gehört ich das bild weil es
zwischendurch eingefroren aber ich denke
wir haben alle ihre botschaft ganz klar
gehört ja schreiben ist das so ist das
im moment seit es ja sozusagen mehr frei
oder die falten freiheiten wieder etwas
gibt für die geimpften haben sie das
gefühl dass das darin ganz stark dazu
beiträgt zu dem wunsch auch wirklich
geimpft zu werden wie empfinden sie das
ist natürlich ein super komplexes thema
das immer schwierig die antworten klein
zu halten
aber ich meine stiko hat zwar noch keine
empfehlung offizielle ausgesprochen was
aber natürlich schon im raum stand und
das muss ich ganz klar unterstützen ist
die forderung dass man gesagt hat
vorbelastete also vor erkrankte
schülerin und schüler die brauchen
natürlich dann die impfung und das wäre
auch ein signal heute zumindest für den
anfang gewesen dass manche sagen hätte
können dass dieser impfgipfel ganz klar
sagt menschen bzw
kinder und jugendliche mit
vorerkrankungen die werden jetzt behütet
die werden geschützt und es ist
sicherlich so dass viele jetzt merken
mit der impfung da braucht man den test
nicht mehr da kann man sich viele
freiheiten wieder bekommen und und
sicherlich das ein aspekt aber der
anderen das muss ich ganz klar sagen
seit dieser pandemie mich erreichen bis
heute ganz viele schülerinnen und
schüler nachrichten die wirklich sagen
ich habe die vorerkrankung oder ich habe
meine eltern meine oma die die erkrankt
sind an xy die übrigens auch noch nicht
alle geimpft sind und die sagen
natürlich ich möchte diese impfung weil
ich mich aber auch meine verwandten
möchte und es ist natürlich auch so dass
auch junge menschen einfach an corona
erkranken können seltener als alter aber
es kann passieren von daher
es ist ein gemisch aus allem und ich
glaube es wäre fatal einfach zu sagen es
geht darum dass die jungen leute ganz
salopp gesagt wieder party machen wollen
weil das würde der wahrheit nicht
entsprechen
hertha hat wie wichtig ist es dann also
wenn sie jetzt wäre es ja auch von den
specht gehört dass es auf jeden fall
großen sinn macht kinder und jugendliche
zu impfen wie give aber da doch die
meisten kinder nicht so schwer erkranken
kann man dann nicht auch sagen
eigentlich ist es nicht so wichtig es
wäre wichtiger die lehrer und die eltern
zu impfen das wäre prioritär
also ich denke über kurz oder lang wird
auch irgendwann eine generelle
impfempfehlung für kinder oder
jugendliche geben aber ich weiß noch
nicht ob weise die nächste woche schon
haben oder ob erst die risiko
empfehlungen haben aber was ja schon
auch gerade gesagt hat wir haben viele
viele erwachsene die in die
priorisierung gruppen oder in die
altersgruppen gehören die noch nicht
geimpft sind
das sind millionen menschen in
deutschland der siebte sechster ist
wahrscheinlich schon ein korrektes datum
das man aufhören kann mit der
priorisierung weil dann die meisten von
den gruppen die jetzt noch dran sind
eine erste impfung bekommen haben
könnten
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass die
priorisierung eben nicht bundesweit über
also gut eingehalten wurde dass der
impfstoff dort auch für nicht
priorisierte gruppen benutzt wurde und
dadurch wir auch noch ein bisschen
länger brauchen um diese priorisierten
gruppen durch von im moment werden viele
zweitimpfung gemacht diese arbeiten ja
selbst in dem impfzentrum wie ist merken
sie dass sie ja ob das stimmt dass jetzt
viele zweite impfung gemacht wenn das
liegt einfach daran dass die
impfstoffmenge eben nicht so explodiert
es wie wir das erwartet hatten sondern
dass wir halt jetzt erleben dass wir
nicht gleichzeitig genauso für erste
impfung die zweite impfung machen können
aber wir müssen die zweite impfung
machen damit der impfschutz komplett ist
und wir haben halt diese abstände
verlängert deswegen ist die gruppe der
menschen die jetzt auf einen haufen
zweite impfung bekommen muss größer
geworden
und das macht das wirklich logistisch
schwieriger ja wenn ich das jetzt alles
so höhere verdienst dann denkt man doch
war das überhaupt sinnvoll diese
priorisierung aufzuheben
also man hat jetzt der druck ist groß
würden sie sagen ja auch irgendwann muss
man die priorisierung auf wir haben eine
deutsche impfstrategie vor dreiviertel
jahr festgelegt wurde drinsteht sobald
viel impfstoff verfügbar ist und die
priorisierten gruppen alle mindestens
ein
erst impfangebot gab dann soll die
priorisierung aufgehoben werden das
halte ich auch für richtig und ich denke
wenn man strategisch denkt und wenn die
impfstoffmenge wirklich passt dass der
siebte sechster auch ein realistisches
datum sein kann aber jetzt erleben wir
gerade dass der immer wieder etwas
knapper jahren ist bei biotech und das
kann uns wieder zurückwerfen okay wie
sehen sie es die politik hat jetzt
dringend ein signal an die jüngeren
leute senden wollen und auch müssen man
muss einfach mal revue passieren lassen
was in den vergangenen jahr gewesen ist
es sind doch die jungen leute die jetzt
auf der strecke ganz ganz viel gelitten
haben zurück gesteckt haben
wir kriegen immer mehr informationen
darüber wie kinder zuhause leiden unter
dem homeschooling traumatisiert sind
dass es soziale konflikte in den
familien dass es viele familien gibt mit
mehreren kindern wo nicht jedes kind
einen laptop hat das sind alles bekannte
sachen wo dann abwechselnd gelernt wird
die den anschluss verlieren die
vielleicht nicht einfach automatisch ein
jahr wiederholen und wenn das sehr viele
machen würden dann würde es
wahrscheinlich auch zu wenig lehrer
geben und es sollte jetzt so eine ein
positives signal sein auch ihr seid in
unserem fokus auch ihr sollt schnell
geimpft werden und unter diesen schutz
kommen aber jetzt bleibt die kinder die
jugendlichen können sich um einen
impftermin bemühen ist das nicht ein
bisschen wenig anders wäre es schöner
das stimmt schon mal beim impfstoff
astrazeneca sehe wie viele sich nicht
mit astrazeneca impfen lassen wollen da
war das sehr wichtig dass frei zu geben
weil es tausende
hunderttausende gibt die sich sehr gerne
mit astrazeneca impfen lassen wollen und
die ein risiko in kauf nehmen wenn sie
jünger als 60 sind und das hat ja auch
ganz viel in bewegung gebracht und
vielleicht gibt es da ja auch noch
spielräume dass man das nicht alles da
horden muss und sondern doch noch mal
dafür werden kann das
ohne dass man so dass man es eben sich
nicht aussuchen kann für den impfstoff
ja das ist dann wiederum schwierig wenn
man so viel über astra weniger gut
aufgeklärt hatte sehr transparent
gemacht hat und dann die leute
verpflichtet sich damit zu empfindlich
hat ich habe das gefühl dass sehr viele
menschen freiwillig auch sehr viel
jüngere menschen freiwillig astrazeneca
nehmen und vielleicht gibt es darüber
auch bewegungen und dann wieder
spielräume an an anderer stelle und dass
man das jetzt einfach laufen lässt und
was ich ganz wichtig finde das im
letzten jahr ist sind die sommerferien
sehr verplempert worden man hat vieles
nicht gemacht was man eigentlich wusste
was hätte was man hätte tun müssen
dieses mal wenn man dieses mal vor den
sommerferien anfängt und schon etwas an
schiebt und sachen öffnet und möglich
macht habe ich doch die hoffnung dass
das dass der start ins nächste schuljahr
für die kinder und jugendlichen
abgesicherter und besser und besser
strukturiert wird herr schramm was
brauchen schülerinnen und schüler jetzt
um was könnte man jetzt sozusagen wir
damit beginnen damit das nächste
schuljahr dann sind sie fertig mit der
schule aber was was für andere
schülerinnen und schüler für das neue
schuljahr was dann beginnt was muss da
anders sein als im letzten jahr
wenn wir uns jetzt auch möglich
konzentrieren dann haben wir schon vor
zwei wochen gesagt dass man sich
wirklich die gedanken darüber machen
muss dass man wirklich versuchen muss in
den schulen zu impfen zumindest das
impfangebot zu geben und da bin ich ganz
dankbar das land niedersachsen mit
ministerpräsident weil der ja heute nach
dieser konferenz gesagt hat er ist
unzufrieden damit weil er hätte gerne
diesen plan verfolgt dass man die
schüler vor den sommerferien wirklich
die erste impfung verabreicht das wäre
ein ganz wichtiger schritt gewesen es
hätte die erste impfung vor den
sommerferien geben müssen
jetzt müsste sie geben ich hab schon so
pessimistisch geredet dass ich davon
ausgehe dass das nicht passieren wird
aber es müsste vor den sommerferien die
erste dosis geben in den sommerferien
die zweite denn das rechnerische problem
was wir haben auch mit der versprechung
von der kanzlerin heute am ende des
sommers oder an der ende august wie
ersparen das gesagt hat ist das kann man
ganz schnell ausrechnen man hat sechs
wochen vorgegeben erst die zweite
impfung bei montech da liegen wir im
bereich von anfang november
und da ist das schuljahr im vollen gange
und das bedeutet da hätte man den start
verpasst bedeutet man muss wirklich
jetzt damit beginnen aber ist das ist
das wichtigste
also
ich wundere mich dass er jetzt muss man
nicht hätte maniche was ist brauchen
schülerinnen und schüler nicht was ganz
anderes eigentlich nein das war jetzt
zumindest wenn man es auf das im prinzip
was das wichtigere ist das
allerwichtigste in wenn es um das
inhaltliche geht mal weg von dem thema
impfen ist das dass man die schüler
ankommen lässt ob sie jetzt langsam
wieder in die schulen kommen in berlin
ist es ja noch wechsel unterricht und da
kommen sie hoffentlich nach den ferien
dann in gesammelter mannschaft wieder
ist dass die schüler den raum bekommen
das erlebte zu verarbeiten was wir
aktuell in deutschland erleben ist dass
die ganzen schüler wieder in das gebäude
kommen die lehrer sind total im stress
weil sie versuchen irgendwie noch eine
leistungsfähige sachen auf die reihe zu
bekommen bewertungs fähige sachen und
das darf nicht passieren also die
schüler am immens viel erlebt sie haben
lange zeit vielleicht nicht den sozialen
kontakt gab es auch wichtig ist in dem
in dem zeitraum von daher wenn es die
schule wieder losgeht dann muss die
schule erstmal der ort des ankommt sein
des austausches und eben nicht des
leistungsdrucks und direkt schauen wie
können wir in den lehrplan durchziehen
specht hat die politik die kinder und
jugendliche vernachlässigt und versucht
man das jetzt über das eben von irgend
etwas gutzumachen was man es versäumt
hat ja ja ich glaube dieser eindruck ist
nicht ganz falsch und ich weiß aber
nicht ob das das richtige und die
richtige maßnahme damit getroffen ist
denn die frage ist ja immer beim impfen
nicht man muss die frage beantworten
sollten wir impfen oder sollten wir
nicht impfen wenn ich impfe wenn ich
eine medizinische maßnahme machen muss
ich immer einen guten grund dafür haben
und mich beschleicht einfach das gefühl
dass aktuell sowohl in der politik als
auch bei vielen schülern und auch
natürlich bei eltern das gefühl da ist
oder der wunsch da ist ich brauche die
impfung hauptsächlich für meine
freiheiten und das finde ich eine leider
sehr schlechte begründung für eben für
eine impfung wenn wir hier erkennen dass
die politik versucht wie sie eben
formuliert haben etwas wiedergutzumachen
dann muss man da ja nicht unbedingt
mitgehen eine impfung ist mit sicherheit
dann sinnvoll wenn ich auch im
individuum also den der da geimpft wird
wirklich einen großen nutzen zuteil
werden lasse das ist aber bei dieser
impfung zumindest noch für mich nicht so
ganz klar
natürlich heißt das auch dass die
schüler und schülerinnen wenn sie dann
eben nicht geimpft und er sagte ja die
bundeskanzlerin heute auch natürlich
kein nacht
haben dürfen und wenn das natürlich dann
wiederum heißt ja wenn ihr nicht geimpft
sein dann müsst ihr aber regelmäßig
tests an bringen dann ist natürlich klar
dass jeder sagt dann möchte ich mal
bitte auch geimpft sein
ich bin vielleicht gar kein impfen aber
egal ich möchte diese dieser
bescheinigung haben dass hier die ich
aber für völlig falsch
aber wie sollte man es denn dann machen
also was war heute wichtig zu sagen es
ist auf jeden fall findet
schulunterricht statt
unabhängig von der impfung was wäre denn
dann sind wir es wurde ja eben schon
auch gesagt wir haben natürlich viel
versäumt im vergangenen sommer hätte man
schon viel tun können an anderen
maßnahmen die man auch in schulen in
größeren räumen hätte treffen können
es bleibt aber bei der medizinischen
einschätzung dass die infektionsgefahr
für diese jungen menschen relativ
geringes beziehungsweise die gefahr für
einen schweren kubik 19 verlauf und das
muss letztendlich unsere maßstab sein
wir können ja nicht die kinder sozusagen
jetzt auch noch in geiselhaft nehmen und
sagen so ihr musstet jetzt schon lange
warten er muss jetzt extrem euch
einschränke neuer risiko war zwar nie
groß aber jetzt müsste jetzt was sie
auch noch mal warten oder ihr müsst eine
impfung haben damit ihr dann wieder im
normalen leben am normalen leben
teilhaben können
das hielte ich nicht für richtig wir
müssen was ganz anderes machen wir
müssen die die wirklich ein hohes risiko
tragen ein impfangebot machen und zwar
zu viel und so gut wie irgendwie möglich
und dann natürlich auch diejenige dem
risiko tragen von den jüngeren impfen
die ganz jungen wenn das dann mal auch
noch kommen sollte wie die amerikaner
das ja auch schon im blick haben die
würde ich sowieso da außen vor lassen
hertha hat wie wichtig ist es dass
kinder geimpft sind damit
schulunterricht normal stattfinden kann
oder würden sie sagen wo die heute da
mal eben betont hat eben schon gesagt
schulunterricht soll auf jeden fall
stattfinden unabhängig von den impfungen
kann es unabhängig von den impfungen
seien
aus meiner sicht ja also die das im ziel
kann aus meiner sicht oder auch sich der
stiko nicht sein gesellschaftliche
teilhabe oder schule das im ziel ist ein
individueller medizinischen nutzen der
abgewogen wird gegen ein medizinisches
risiko und das machen wir gerade in der
bearbeitung dieser impfung und das
medizinische risiko hat
spricht gerade gesagt bei jugendlichen
es halt nicht so groß dass man sofort
sagt das muss jetzt allen kindern
jugendlichen gegeben werden
und ich halte es schon für möglich auch
zu warten bis das dann irgendwann mal
der fall ist und trotzdem schon schule
zu machen
mit konzepten die es jetzt schon gibt
mit weiterhin test strategien um halt
schnell cluster zu erkennen und halt
gruppen zu isolieren die sich
gegenseitig dann doch noch anstecken
könnten
und ich würde wüsste nicht warum wir
damit noch lange warten sollten denn die
gruppe der menschen die wir vor allen
dingen schützen wollten dies zum großen
teil geimpft noch nicht alle aber die am
schwersten gefährdeten menschen sind
mittlerweile geschützt durch impfung und
erkrankung ja auch kaum noch und das
risiko das von den kindern ausgeht in
die schule gehen dass ihnen die familie
zu tragen spielt nicht mehr so eine
große rolle wie das noch vor fünf
monaten der fall war okay trotzdem fragt
man sich ja war hätte man nicht weiß auf
was anderes mehr wert legen müssen von
uns also wird gerade wenn man sieht man
hat ja denn den eindruck der druck ist
jetzt da war halt eben auch die ferien
vor der tür stehen und das ist
vielleicht dann doch mehr darum geht
dass man als familie geimpft in den
urlaub fahren kann dass das wichtiger
ist als die gesundheitsvorsorge weil wir
uns alle jetzt im moment ein bisschen
sicherer fühlen weil doch schon einige
geimpft sind
das war auch im vorigen jahr schon so
dass der urlaub über wochen das größte
thema in deutschland war und das ist ein
großen aufschrei gab wenn man nicht nach
mecklenburg vorpommern fahren konnte
oder seine reisepläne nicht so umsetzen
konnte wie man das zu beginn des jahres
gedacht hatte das passiert jetzt wieder
aber jetzt mit einer anderen wucht
meiner meinung nach es ist doch eine
erschöpfung in der gesellschaft zu
spüren und die die bilder die wir jetzt
gesehen haben wenn cafés eröffnen und
menschen dort sitzen und sich wirklich
über den kaffee freund der ihnen
serviert wird das hier in gesellschaft
draußen sitzen können und dass sie es
spricht viel dafür was doch entbehrt
wurde und das kann man glaube ich nicht
mehr nur abtun dass man sagt wir können
auch mal auf urlaub verzichten sondern
es geht wirklich darum den geist zu weit
was anderes zu erleben sich nicht mehr
so einzuigeln sich nicht immer nur auf
sich selbst konzentrieren zu müssen
sondern
sich doch insgesamt wieder zu öffnen das
positive zu sehen und dass da der wunsch
einher geht dass die familie geimpft in
urlaub fahren kann das kann ich wirklich
sehr verstehen und trotzdem muss man
jetzt noch mal sagen das hat ja specht
gerade auch an geschnitten es geht darum
was schützt den menschen das ist die
impfung und das ist nicht der urlaub und
deswegen müsste man trotzdem noch mal
sagen auch diesen sommer müssen wir noch
vorsichtiger angehen so stark zu ihren
alten ändern
genau das stimmt dass das haben wir aber
schon ein paar mal gedacht jetzt erhöht
sich zwar zugleich die im vorletzten
seite also aber es gibt auch immer
wieder die bedenken von wissenschaftlern
die sagen man weiß noch nicht ob
geimpften die ich auch noch über träger
sind das trifft dann die die die nicht
geimpft sind also ich will ja immer noch
so versucht zu sagen ein paar wochen
müssen wir den laden noch zusammenhalten
oder jedem bild je mehr zeit wir
gewinnen desto einfacher wird es und
trotzdem ist es so dass die dass dieses
signal sein muss wir kommen damit voran
und wir versuchen es auf ganz breiter
ebene jetzt mit allen schwierigkeiten
und mit allen rückschlägen herr schramma
hat es gesagt hat die zeit ausgerechnet
wann das soweit sein würde die muss man
noch weiter eigentlich heute auch wieder
gewarnt hat gesagt wir sind da noch wir
sind noch nicht durch die pandemie wir
haben es nicht geschafft auch herr söder
sagte wir sind noch nicht über dem berg
herrscht recht nehmen wir das alles
inzwischen zu locker weil weil wir immer
mehr menschen kennen die sich die
geimpft sind
das glaube ich eigentlich nicht
natürlich gibt es einzelne dies von
anfang an überhaupt nicht ernst genommen
haben und andere die die ganze zeit
es mit der panik übertreiben um es mal
so zu sagen aber ich glaube man muss
doch mal klar erkennen wer gedacht hat
diese pandemie ist etwas die wird mal
angestellt und irgendwann fc dann auch
einfach ab und dann ist es weg und saß
koch 2 spielt keine rolle mehr
die werden sich täuschen das wird nicht
so sein wir wissen inzwischen sachs co 2
das virus wird bleiben wenn wir in zehn
jahren untersuchungen machen werden wer
weiß ob er dann auch noch testen
dann werden wir dieses virus nach wie
vor finden wir werden nach wie vor
infektionen finden wir werden wenn alles
gut geht sie viel weniger
krankheitsfälle sehen vor allen dingen
schwere krankheitsfälle und auch sehr
wenige todesfälle wir werden aber
trotzdem auch todesfälle sehen wir
kriegen es nicht komplett weg aber ein
junger mensch von heute einmal besonders
junger mensch fünf jahre
er wird mit diesem virus zurecht kommen
weil neue viren sind für ihn der
normalfall
er muss sich ja an alle während die wir
schon kennen als erwachsene muss er ja
auch erst kennenlernen dann baut sich
die immunabwehr auf sein immunsystem ist
aber dafür bestens ausgerüstet mit
gerade diesen neuen viren
zurechtzukommen
dh er wird viele varianten noch sehen
und wenn er mal 20 30 jahre alt ist dann
kommt er mit diesen viren sowieso in der
ganzen zeit schon weil er immer so eine
teilimmunität aufgebaut hat sehr sehr
gut zurecht und problem war dass jetzt
und ist es immer noch für uns ältere für
die erwachsenen und dann vor allen
dingen die besonders älteren und
immungeschwächten chronisch kranken weil
die haut so war es natürlich um und das
wollten wir nicht die impfung
sensationell dass das so schnell
gegangen ist kann da einen ganz
wertvollen beitrag leisten aber er hat
ja auch schon gesagt die bullen in
gruppen das haben wir am anfang ja immer
gesagt hängebrücken müssen geschützt
werden das ist jetzt recht gut gelungen
das ist gut gelungen trotzdem mal bitte
das ist ja diese frage wir kommen jetzt
in unseren dauer im modus ja
wahrscheinlich weil wir auch dann die
älteren die jetzt schon im dezember
vielleicht die erste impfung könnte
vielleicht damit bald wieder geimpft
werden müssen und wir haben immer noch
nicht genügend impfstoff also müssen wir
doch dann doch irgendwo eine
priorisierung machen solange wir nicht
genügend impfstoff für unsere
bevölkerung haben brauchen wir eine
priorisierung durch diese priorität zu
impfenden gruppen abgearbeitet sind
ich würde das gerne noch ein bisschen
globaler öffnen geräten die ganze zeit
über unsere bevölkerung und priorisieren
dort wenn wir global priorisieren
müssten wir noch viel länger brauchen
weil wir auf der welt viele gruppen von
menschen haben die den impfstoff noch
viel dringender brauchen erst jetzt bei
uns die die jetzt ganz laut schreien und
das ist der appell nicht so sehr so
national zu denken in diesem sinn die
hersteller denken auch global biotech
liefert millionen hunderte millionen
dosen des impfstoffs an die ganze welt
und nicht nur an deutschland und auch
die verteilung wird halt so gemacht dass
die jederzeit verteilen an alle länder
eine diese verträge haben und auch an
ärmere länder wird impfstoff geliefert
und kofinanziert durch andere
organisationen und wir regen uns immer
nur über uns hier in deutschland auf und
ich glaube wir haben auf der welt viel
größeres problem mit 19 als wir das im
moment in deutschland mittlerweile haben
und ich denke wir sollten alle ein
bisschen bescheidener ein bisschen
devote auftreten und nicht immer denken
wir müssen jetzt ganz schnell
herauskommen wir sind noch lange nicht
raus wenn die welt nicht raus ist weil
die gefahr gibt der virus varianten
natürlich das ist das so freut uns was
ist ihr eindruck von der politik dass da
im moment einfach weil wir haben ja auch
noch eine bundestagswahl die hier kommt
dass man es einfach sich deshalb auch so
stark darauf konzentriert dass es hier
gut läuft ich würde jetzt erstmal
wirklich sagen wir haben einen impfplan
wir haben impfdosen wir haben eine
strategie gehabt und die hat diese
schritte vorgesehen da jetzt raus zu
brechen und zu sagen wir schicken ein
paar millionen dosen in andere länder
wird überhaupt nicht gehen hat überhaupt
keine akzeptanz grundsätzlich ist es
genau so dass man international denken
muss weil wir sehen dass über indien und
großbritannien und brasilien
die mutanten wieder wieder zurückkommen
dann hängt davon ab wie gut sind die
impfstoffe dagegen ausgerüstet wir sind
wir abwehrbereit gegen so etwas nur die
die das dass dieses land mit denen mit
den impfdosen die er beklagt wurden viel
zu wenig gewesen seien sowieso erstmal
kämpfen muss also wir haben ja halt
lange die diskussion gehabt dass
deutschland
im rahmen der eu verhandelt hat und die
eu-kommission das ganze hat machen
lassen und deswegen habe deutschland
angeblich zu wenig bekommen oder
langsamer und sagen wir also weiter das
haben wir ja schon
wir waren ja eben nicht der nationale
vordrängler wir haben das nicht versucht
abgeschottet zu machen damals eben mit
der idee mit vielen ländern gemeinsam
sondern die bundeskanzlerin die
bundesregierung haben eu-weit gedacht
jetzt muss der nächste schritt und
international gemacht werden dass die
bundestagswahl da ein großes druck
element ist dass es ja ganz klar das ist
meiner ansicht nach kein zufall dass die
bundeskanzlerin den termin 21 september
gewählt hat dass alle bürger ein ins
angebot schreiben das weiß ich noch
sagen
sie hatte von einem impfangebot
gesprochen was also auch ein erstes
angebot einschließt das kann sein dass
ich dann am 20
september im brief bekommen sagt im
november habe ich meine erste info nein
ich nicht so verstanden dass man das
erst im angebot hat und dann aber ein
angebot sozusagen für die zweite impfung
und fünf tage später ist die
bundestagswahl
das ist auf der anderen seite ein risiko
denn wenn das nicht klappt wird das auch
bei der dann zwar nicht wieder
antretenden kanzlerin einzahlen
also nicht gerade bei ihrer partei bei
der union also insofern hat sie da schon
eine messlatte gelegt die sie unbedingt
einhalten muss und deswegen wird
natürlich jetzt auch alles daran die
front geworfen dass das genau so kommt
und trotzdem sind wir ja nach den
berechnungen was wir an impfstoff dosen
bekommen noch im plan auch wenn es
derzeit noch verzögerungen gibt ist ja
die aussicht dass das im august dann
noch mal auf
also groß aufgestockt wird auf jeden
fall da ja wohl die zahlen noch nicht
ganz klar ist was geliefert wird also da
gibt es ja noch super lehrstellen in
diesem genau gab es ja heute so ja zu
sehen einen plan und da war für das
zweite quartal ist jetzt erstmal eine
irritationen da so genau ich würde ganz
gerne mal auf dieses thema gerechtigkeit
kann man auch die frage nach
gerechtigkeit in dieser pandemie
schreiben weil er viele sagen jetzt ja
die die jugendlichen auch die studenten
adedy haben
doch sehr gelitten und die haben ja ein
bisschen aus dem blick verloren am
anfang haben wir nur auf die guckt die
wirklich sehr gefährdet sind
auf wen finden sie müsste man denn jetzt
am meisten eigentlich gucken wo haben
sie das gefühl wo geht es eigentlich
nicht so gerecht zu gerade wenn es jetzt
darum geht dass man sich um einen
impftermin zum beispiel bemühen muss das
hat glaube ich hat specht eben gesagt er
hatte gesagt den satz alle wohl in der
abeln gruppen sind abgedeckt und dann
möchte ich ganz klar widersprechen weil
das ist auch dass ich sehe das auch als
mal eine aufgabe heute das nochmal ganz
klar zu thematisieren wir haben eben
schülerinnen und schüler im alter 12 bis
15 jahre die vor erkrankt sind die
warten seit wochen darauf dass diese
zulassung der ema kommt weil sie dann
die möglichkeit haben sich eben aber
dazu brauchen sie ja selbst zustimmen
weil das haben wir genau wir brauchen
die zu lassen schon ganz klar der ema
aber darauf warten die und dann haben
wir jetzt das ding und das ist die
ansage die diese menschen von der
bundesregierung heute bekommen haben ja
wenn die wenn die zulassung da ist
natürlich könnt ihr euch impfen lassen
aber stellt euch in dieselbe reihe wie
alle anderen auch und das muss man sich
vorstellen das sind viele schülerinnen
und schüler gerade in dem alter mittlere
jahrgänge die waren lange zeit zu hause
die ganzen anderen ich sag mal probleme
schäden die irgendwie corona in der zeit
verursacht haben und jetzt sagt man
diesen menschen noch zusätzlich ja
stelle ich ihr kriegt es den impfstoff
wald wenn er dann zugelassen wird aber
stellt euch damit in die reihe und das
ist wirklich was durch sagen muss dass
es schwer gerade jungen menschen zu
vermitteln wenn es darum geht euch zu
schützen oder gerade in jungen menschen
wieder das gefühl von schützen
vermitteln zu wollen
da haben sie völlig recht herr schreiben
das ist sicher eine lücke auch in der
priorisierung die wir haben das halt an
die risikogruppen in den jüngeren
jahrgängen bisher nicht richtig gedacht
wurde
wir haben die ganzen diagnosen in der
priorisierung schlimmste die halt auch
die erwachsenen zu treffen aber halt es
fehlen sicherlich ein paar die jüngere
generation angeht aber das arbeiten wir
gerade nach aber das kann man das so
wäre dann wäre es doch aber ich wollte
nur noch mal bei ihnen nachfragen das
kann man doch dann so verstehen dass die
stiko genau diese priorisierung
vorschlagen
wird also wir sind noch dabei das
erarbeiten wir sind noch nicht so ganz
beendet es fehlen noch ein paar
modellierung und wissenschaftliche daten
dazu und wir müssen einfach sagen es
fehlen daten zu den risiken des
impfstoffes in der altersgruppe und wir
werden eine empfehlung abgeben und das
die risikogruppen dabei sind da bin ich
jetzt schon sicher ob noch was darüber
hinausgeht kann ich noch nicht sagen
und die risikogruppen müssen sehr gut
definiert werden und da sind sicherlich
ein paar noch dabei die bis jetzt in
dieser gruppe noch nicht drin sind die
jetzige priorisierung empfehlung ist ja
zu einem zeitpunkt verabschiedet worden
als an die kinder einfach noch gar nicht
gedacht worden war
da hatten wir eben einen impfstoff der
ab 16 jahren zugelassen war
die galten mit als die erwachsenen und
wir haben gar nicht damit gerechnet dass
wir im mai überhaupt schon über
kinderimpfungen reden wir haben immer
gedacht das wird august september und
wir sind jetzt überrascht worden wie so
oft von biontech dass das so schnell
gegangen ist und die ema hat jetzt die
unterlagen gesehen wir haben sie eine
stieg gesagt gerade anderthalb zwei
wochen zur verfügung und können diese
studien daten einsehen und müssen halt
jetzt die andere wissenschaftliche
arbeit dazu leisten viel plötzlicher und
schneller als wir das vorher gedacht
hatten
und deswegen brauchen wir jetzt auch
noch eine woche und jemand so in form
eines würden heisst ja mal kinder sind
ja nicht kleine erwachsene also gibt man
denen dann die gleiche dosis oder wie
muss man sich das handy soll das ist
derselbe impfstoff der jetzt schon
verfügbar ist er nur eine erweiterte
erweiterte zulassung bekommt in den
altersgruppen darunter wird die
dosierung höchstwahrscheinlich geändert
werden vor allem bei den ganz kleinen da
laufen die studien gerade noch und die
brauchen auch deutlich länger noch ein
kurzer hinweis was heute in der
pressekonferenz von allen dreien
politikern gesagt wurde genau dass die
erkrankten kinder und jugendlichen
so haben sie den eindruck erweckt auf
jeden fall eine empfehlung für
priorisierung bekommen werden und dann
könnte ich mir auch den normalen ärzte
verstand vorstellen dass hausärzte sehr
genau darauf gucken werden so wie sie es
jetzt auch schon machen wer so etwas
braucht und da dann auch eine eigene
priorisierung selbst verantwortlich
jackson werden was ja schreiben auch
gesagt hat die gerade die eltern dieser
kinder sind ja schon sehr aktiv und die
werden sehr sehr schnell auch jetzt
schon handeln und die sind auch schon
auf listen in ihren kinderarzt und
hausarztpraxen ich denke das werden wir
hinkriegen das ist eine gruppe von 15
bis 20 prozent dieser altersgruppe
ja ok aber es ist ja doch eine ganze
menge ist ja eigentlich schon
erstaunlich dass die sozusagen bisher
vergessen worden ist ja vergessen nicht
wir haben nicht 16 bis 17 jährigen
bisher im kopf gehabt
genau ich glaube man kann nicht sagen
vergessen man muss sich das ganze ja mal
vorstellen normalerweise wäre eine
impfstoff entwicklung in diesem
wahnsinnigen tempo überhaupt niemals
vorstellbar gewesen dass wir jetzt hätte
er hat gerade gesagt dass wir jetzt über
kinderimpfungen schönreden selbst vor
ein paar monaten hatten wir noch gesagt
na ja also frühestens irgendwann im
dezember kann man mal darüber nachdenken
das wären dann auch eher die älteren
geworden
eltern kinder ist man die ganz jungen
erst ins auge fasst also von daher denke
ich es kann natürlich nicht sein dass
diese auch holen raten gruppen also die
vorerkrankung sich dann jetzt wieder wie
er schreibt sagte hinten anstellen
müssen das kann nicht sein
das sehe ich aber auch überhaupt nicht
insofern muss ich da eine lanze brechen
für die die das jetzt auch entwickelt
haben es ist völlig normal dass man bei
impfstoffen natürlich erst einmal
gesunde junge erwachsene auch in den
studien hat das versteht sich von selbst
denn man weiß ja nicht wieder im stoff
so bei den menschen ankommt was er da
anrichtet und dann macht man das
natürlich nicht bei kindern also
überhaupt studien arzneimittelstudien
bei kindern ist immer ganz ganz
schwierig insofern ist es klar dass das
ein bisschen hinten dran hier aber ich
glaube man kann es nicht sagen man hat
sie vergessen man hat er halt gar nicht
gedacht dass es wirklich so schnell
gehen kann
das ist eigentlich eher positive okay
ich würde ganz ganz am schluss einer
ebene auf die frage der ja auch der
sozialen
unterschiede kommen weil wir haben
gesagt wer sich bemüht klar wer einen
hausarzt kennt der ruft einen an der
versucht das dann sein kind einen
impftermin bekommt was ist mit denen die
die weniger zugänge haben die vielleicht
ja in sozial schwierigen verhältnissen
sind die nicht dann eben nicht bemühen
oder deren eltern sich nicht bemühen uns
ist das wird das eigentlich wahrgenommen
oder sollte man nicht sagen man geht
einfach in die schulen und dann so wie
früher wurden auch alle in der schule
geben das ist ja noch in der diskussion
das werden die länder unterschiedlich
wahrscheinlich handhaben
es gibt länder die sagen wir können das
nicht in der schulklasse machen weil wir
in dem moment kinder haben werden deren
eltern das nicht möchten dass ihre
kinder geimpft werden dann haben sie
schon eine soziale spaltung wenn sie das
innerhalb des unterrichts machen
dann soll das auf den nachmittag gelegt
werden in der schule
wohin man sich dann freiwillig begeben
kann diese menschen von denen sie
sprechen brauchen alle erdenkliche hilfe
so wie es das ganze jahr hätte sein
müssen und was in vielen bereichen nicht
geklappt hat und da hat herr schramm
völlig recht wenn die kinder zurück
kommen die kinder und schüler zurück
kommen in das nächste schuljahr muss ich
unbedingt so sein dass erst mal
aufgearbeitet werden kann dass diese
krise die sie einerseits stärker gemacht
haben kann in der sie sehr viel gelernt
haben werden und auf der anderen seite
eine sehr sehr große last mit dran dass
sie das erzählen können und das von dem
anspruch den lernstoff jetzt
durchzuziehen abgesehen wird und dass
man genau drauf schaut wie geht es den
kindern und ihren eltern dann auch und
daran arbeitet das wird vielleicht mehr
bringen fürs leben als irgend eine
besonders tolle arbeit bisher aber
hätten sie es sinnvoll wenn die schule
zum impfzentrum würde wenn man sagt er
wir impfen jetzt ein paar wir machen das
angebot wenn es genug impfstoff gibt und
dann wird einfach in der schule auch
geimpft und dann muss man sich nicht
selber bemühen um einen termin oder die
eltern absolut weil das kann nämlich
genau gegenwirken gegen das was sie
angesprochen haben diese soziale schere
denn das ist in der bildungspolitik ist
schon ein riesen thema gewesen
grundsätzlich und das erleben jetzt auch
bei dem impfen das natürlich die eltern
die ihm zeit haben die sich hinsetzen
können die ruhe haben die sich natürlich
deutlich mehr an
wir können um dann in vier kind wenn wir
das ganze jetzt umdrehen spricht man
kann in der schule das angebot machen
man braucht eben nur die
einverständniserklärung es gibt die
mobilen immobilie die an die schulen
kommen dann kann man dagegen wirken weil
tatsächlich alle irgendwie die
möglichkeit bekommen natürlich ist es so
dass viele sagen ich möchte das nicht in
der großen gruppe machen ich habe
vielleicht auch angst völlig zu recht
ich hab bin auch kein fan von namen und
das design ich möchte zu meinem eigenen
kinderarzt gehen aber ich glaube dass es
tatsächlich gegen die sehr viele
probleme vor wirken kann wenn man sagt
man schickt diese teams an die schulen
man hat dieses angebot und dann kann
immer noch jeder für sich selber
entscheiden aber das wahrnimmt dass die
frage ob jemand dass man selber
entscheiden kann
was sagen sie denn sie haben früher als
kinderarzt gearbeitet hat eine eigene
praxis aber was würden sie denn jetzt
eltern sagen also so werden wenn es um
diese chronisch erkrankten kinder geht
die haben alle ihre betreuenden ärzte
die haben auch kontakte weil die kinder
eben krank sind da mache ich mir nicht
so große sorge auch um die soziale
schere nicht da würde ich mir eher die
sorge machen wenn eine flächendeckende
impfung geht da bräuchten wir alle
angebote die es gibt schule impfungen
kinderarzt impfung impfzentren anders
geht es nicht okay und wir brauchen vor
allem jede menge impfstoff alles gute
ihnen herr schramm feiern sie schon ihr
abitur
das haben sie sich verdient sie für
alles gute dafür verspricht vielen dank
frau dunst hertha hat und in liebe
zuschauer fürs zuschauen für die phoenix
runde und jetzt kommt meine kollegin
konstanzer am platz die mit für nix der
tag und die hat garantiert auch noch mal
eine gute zusammenfassung dieses
impfgipfel schönen guten abend
[Musik]